the bunny
oh
the bunny here
all right bunny
invite
gotta play against the bunny
the bunnies look um
the bunnies look harmless but they do
bite
fear the bunny
all right
fear that bunny all right how about i
start off with c4 i like this
mine the knights aren't going to be an
issue they're going to be on their
natural squares
and uh
what else
oh
all right let's follow through here
these guys are just oh no wonder why it
seems natural it's you do this and we
have a
a regular structure kind of a regular
position for most pieces the bishops
the knights are in a good spot
um knight here or might i want to
consider b4 right now
i like b4
helps my queen get out
and
should we play my bishop here
i think that's a good thing my queen has
no moves right now but
but what here
all right that knight needs to get out
of there
get out of there night whoa actually
knight here threatens a deadly deadly
deadly fork
just pawn push here
or pawn push here
now i'm going to do this for two things
one i want to play here and follow up
with bishop e2 before there's two pieces
trained in this diagonal
if knight b4 was played i think i would
be needing to go with rook c1 let's get
my night out
bishop here to follow
and i'll be ready to castle soon here
hmm
bishop e2
all right well i could do this move and
then if knight b3 i could just react
let's do that i'm not too afraid of the
knight b3 move it's not
it's not like it's supported with the
pawn
so
in fact um
huh well i think this could be a
suggestion after the game because if the
knight really wanted to get to this
square i could have done it with tempo
so in the meantime let me get more
development in oh i just tried to castle
regular you have to drop the king on the
rook in order to castle
uh
now what about my queen up
it seems good
now i'm threatening to get this pawn in
two moves
push chop
push chop
is the threat
okay capture towards the center unless i
have a good reason not to do i have a
good reason not to no
in fact now this could become a problem
the a7 pawn
so i could k and then transition
to uh i could i could have my attention
turned towards the a7 pawn
okay
push now
another thing i'm looking into is
playing d4 d5 and getting a knight to c6
wait a second
why would that even be needed how about
i play knight here threaten this
if the bishop defends i play here
no no no no no
never mind
i don't want to do
that oh
but wait a second
no let's not do that either
i was thinking about knight to a2 to b4
to this square but
i'm not so sure about that
let's see this first let's see how black
reacts to that
if the a pawn moves then it's the b pawn
that i could target next maybe even
bringing this guy all the way over here
for as long as i keep my my d pawn on
its home square
i retain a lot of flexibility maybe d4
maybe d3
if i play d4 right away these knights
can rely upon the e3 square
okay this is what we're having
so maybe b6 okay if i take
and the bishop recaptures that drops
material so let's do this the knight has
to recapture
okay this is dropping stuff now
the classic
uh deflection whenever your pieces are
constrained
in such a way where they're having to
watch over one another protect one
another you set yourself up for the
tactic of deflection
and right now the defending piece is the
one that get is the one that will be uh
getting deflected
trying to chase away the defender
deflect away the defender
that's uh maybe a better way to state it
because it could be a
bit more memorable deflect the defender
if you catch your opponent in a
defensive position
try and deflect the defender
right now bishop takes
and then rook takes bishop is
right around the corner
oh
this is a
a little weird
huh
whoa
oh okay i could do this i was thinking
that after night here chop chop
that um
wait a second
oh okay
now i have this move available
let's go with this now
this is a support point i could have
even no i couldn't have cons no yeah i
could have considered that why i should
have played this move instead of rook to
b1 that was too passive
that was silly
i should have considered a
knight b5 right away
i could rely upon the b5 square as a
home
and uh fortunately i have this move with
the bishop takes rook as a continuation
so let's get over here this is where you
belonged in the first place
and uh
i think knight to d2
let's do it right now for two reasons
bishop
knight
fork
um
notice
um i was able to do this a bit quicker
but i'm not so sure that that move would
be played as quick if the queens were
still around
okay wait a second now my knight is hit
if i take here this pawn is falling
so do i just defend my knight for one
moment
hmm
actually i'm just going to run with this
and give that knight up
i'm going to give this up as well and
just go in for this
variation where i get this pawn
and then go after the c pawn i'm sure
there was a cleaner approach but
hang on to this too
why not
rook check is available this is a little
uncomfortable having to okay well it's
not played if there was a rook check and
i had to go to the corner
there's it's a little bit more work
just guard the night
eventually coming here is going to be
good this is a nice home on e4
and that was covered
that was a miss
time time time time less than a minute
okay
good game let's uh hit the rewind let's
flip the board and let's see where
there's uh
an improvement
this seems natural enough what my
opponent is doing with their king side
fiend keto you'd see that in a regular
chess game but i am gaining a lot of
space on the queen side while black goes
for this
typical setup
i i don't know if
you should allow me to get in these
space gaming moves
i think similar to my c4 move
black should be considering c5
because
you should definitely as black
be anticipating that white will play b4
because
not only for the bishop fianchetto but
also because just the queen wants to see
and i could see moves like uh
i could see moves like b4 a4 is a
follow-up i'll spit gaining space
pressing forward towards my queen side
making or
pressing towards the black queen side
and making life until very difficult for
the pieces you already have developed in
this case it was
shown in the form of an eventual b5 and
your knight has to go elsewhere
and it was uh flushed away to the edge
of the board
so
my suggestion in other words is to
really look into
to take into account maybe what it is i
will be looking to play
namely this b4 move maybe you should run
with first c5
not declare your bishop's intentions
just yet maybe you still want to go here
maybe you want to come out in this
direction
maybe don't tell white that
much information so quickly
i think c5 and then knight here
will be a big improvement
um
you get pushed around a bit and this
becomes awkward
this pawn that deep in uh
your position
so
yeah this is this is difficult to defend
this is pretty difficult to defend i
think uh at the very least you need to
be taken with the knight to maintain
material
but even so this is a weak link
and your knight is offsides
so
yeah i think that earlier pawn push
will accomplish a a good amount there
look into the c5 advance and then follow
up with the knight to c6 just as you
would see in a symmetrical
english opening
c4 c5 knight c3 knight c6
this is a good spot for this knight from
this arrangement of pieces
so maybe uh maybe that
anyhow uh good game
duke team